sauerkraut
so sieht es aus und so kommt es auf den
tisch mit eis beiden kasseler oder mit
würsten sauerkraut ist weltberühmt
alle kennen fast alle doch bevor mama es
machen kann müssen kohlköpfe geerntet
werden sauerkraut entsteht aus
vergorenem und damit konserviertem
weißkohl und er kommt vor allem aus dem
norden deutschlands dem landkreis
dithmarschen mitten in dithmarschen den
größten kohlanbaugebiet europas führt
tanja möller zusammen mit ihrem mann
hieß ein restaurant
hier bereitet tanja möller einige für
die region typische sauerkraut gerichte
zu
gern gegessen sauerkraut kalt als salat
angerichtet mit schinken äpfeln und
gehackten nüssen dazu kräuter und taiwan
doch bekannter ist warmes sauerkraut
eine variante sauerkraut auflauf eines
der beliebtesten gerichte der regierung
die deftige sauerkraut fange mit wurst
schweinenacken bohnen und für die
besondere note birnen und apfelstücke in
apfelmus angerichtet wir machen es mit
fleisch rind und das ist ganz typisch
für diese region dass man das süße mit
den salzigen verbindet sauerkraut deftig
und süß sauer angerichtet eine
norddeutsche spezialität keine zehn
kilometer entfernt in der stadt
wesselburen gibt es in einer ehemaligen
sauerkrautfabrik das sogenannte
kolosseum ein museum rund um den kohl
anbau dazu gehört auch eine crowd
werkstatt in der jedes jahr 160 tonnen
bio sauerkraut produziert werden
museumsgründer hubert nickels
entwickelte ein eigenes verfahren mit
dem der weißkohl erst nach der abfüllung
im glas zu sauerkraut verkehrt
jetzt kommen diese verschlossenen leder
in einem vergärung und in diesen verkehr
und verkehrt dieses produkt sieben tage
lang bei einer der raumtemperatur von 18
bis 20 grad
ob zu eisbein kassler oder burger
sauerkraut ist noch mehr als eine
beliebte beilage nicht ohne grund trage
deutsche im ausland den spitznamen kraut